dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
英語のネイティブにとって日本語は非常に難しい言語であるしかし日本語の最も難しい
多そうなんだろう
sob の文法独特のな魚それとも昔からのことわざや英語のネイティブにとって
日本語の最もむず
香椎要素カタカナ語の発音であると言ったら思わず笑ってしまう人がいると思う
こいつは決してなめてはいけない怪獣でアフ以前話したように僕はカタカナ語があまり
好きじゃないけどどうしても使わなければならない時がそのどうしてもという時に備え
て今日はカタカナ語の発音練習をしたいと思う
カリフォルニア種
th
ロスの3ジェスのロー3世です
ロスロサンゼルス
ロサンゼルス
30 f 30です
ロース
のスノ
ペニー知るペ2
演奏レーニャペンそれー new
ペンシルバニア
フィリーフィリから来たって
th
pass
艇ブルー
艇ブルーシー my page ones ちゃ
none
エスノセントリズム
分
ん
本堂
3ハリーセール件レクチャー
うん
レース
アンドリューアンドリューん
bl
ぺー cartoon a ツアー道具
野党減の破損フェア
やはいじゃん
ミス当選
ん
楽しいですな
を
続いの落ち着かね結果いる
ブルーへ
補選をなウェスナフェな子ですね
question ブレーキウェーバーナースああ
ねっと思います
マクドナルド省略してマック
ファンキー資金
省略してファッキン
ファイナルファンタシー
じゃなくてファイナル付
ファイナルファンタジー
たんねんっ透明
豚塁打だけトン台だったっけ
とんっ
oha
car
me